What is the best way to increase my platelet numbers?
so
From a natural perspective to increase
First of all take a step back always we want to know why something so I have low platelets on my
on my blood test
We want to investigate why no, it's not uncommon for a person with cancer to have
Decrease platelet numbers
So the cancer could be that it's very common for different cancer drugs to decrease platelet numbers
So you know we'd have to look at that. So we'd want to find the reason why first
Well, that's a the reason why is not really
Something we can change. Let's say it's because of a medication that I have to be out or whatever
What are some natural ways to increase platelet numbers?
Well red meat could help with platelet numbers, vegetables
Can help with playing the numbers fruit could help with platelet numbers
So there's a lot of different foods that can help benefit platelet numbers many times people have low platelets
Because they're not eating
You know enough protein. They're not eating enough food. So they may have
Some decrease red blood cell count he would go but have adequate a low platelet count
Partially because they're not consuming enough food. It's very common with people as they age and it's very common with people with you know cancer
Especially stage three or stage four cancer. So we want to make sure that we're eating enough meat because
That protein content is not going to only help increase our red blood cell count
He would go but it had a great platelet numbers, but it will also
Give us the ability to make the white blood cells necessary the T cells of the natural killer cells to help kill cancer and
Unfortunately many times we're not feeling well. We don't eat so we want to make sure our protein content is up as well